John: Hey, I've got an idea. Hank: What's your idea?
J: I want you to say "Good morning, John" and then I'll be like "Good morning!"
H: Okay, that-we've had that idea before. J: I know, it's still funny though.
H: Good morning, John! J: Good morning!
J: Ahh! We're together!
("Song for the Painfully Indie" by Tom Milsom plays)
(song ends)
J: I wouldn't do that for a thousand dollars. Katherine: I don't think I would enjoy that either.
H: Punishment! K: That's a little too high.
J: Yeah, that's not a funny punishment.
H: Punishment! We'll make you do the Frog Hopper!
J: Not gonna do it. H: It'd be all over the place.
J: I literally wouldn't do that for a thousand dollars. I might not do it for ten thousand dollars.
I don't want to do that at all.